we live
[Applause]
in an imperfect world a world where
things are never as simple as you want
them to be we're Triumph is often
accompanied by tragedy where there may
be Silver Lining but you can't forget
the Dark Cloud inside of it
which meant that in my life yesterday an
occasion that should have been joyous
and celebratory was marred by hatred and
bigotry and cruelty
now first the good news many outlets
including variety announced yesterday
the all-star cast for this season of the
ABC hit show Dancing with the Stars
there are a number of names that you may
or may not recognize but probably not
Tyson Beckford Adrian Peterson that girl
from American Pie and also right there
plain as day Matt Walsh yes Matt Walsh
will be on Dancing With the Stars as you
may or may not know my name is Matt
Walsh which means that yes I will be on
Dancing With the Stars told you that I
had some big projects on the way
remember I told you that and uh now you
know about one of them now there were
some people on the internet when this
was announced who
started to engage in Wild speculation
spreading false information about there
being another Matt Walsh out there who
is some kind of actor who appeared
allegedly in the show a Veep and they
tried to negate my own achievements by
claiming that this other Matt Walsh is
the one who will appear on Dancing With
the Stars this sort of fake news was bad
enough
but even worse were all the many people
there were great many of them who
rightly assumed that I was going to be
on the TV show but were for some reason
extremely upset about it
to appear on Dancing With the Stars has
been my dream since I was a very young
child and yet these people danced all
over my dream the way that I will be
dancing on that stage when season 32
starts just a quick sample of some of
the things that these haters said on
Twitter just reading a few of the
comments why the f is ABC giving a
platform to far-right bigot Matt Walsh
another says why the f is Matt Walsh on
Dancing With the Stars a lot of comments
like that
um also something tells me that
Christoph fascist and transphobic and
homophobic Matt Walsh will regret making
a fool of himself on Dancing With the
Stars like who told you this was a good
idea Matt you're literally gifting the
people you hate with enough ammo to
launch a war
another says I'm sorry why the f is Matt
Walsh here another says I think it's
ridiculous that this huge show Dancing
with the Stars is letting racist
misogynistic anti-lgbtq plus commentator
Matt Walsh be filmed be better I mean we
missed out on some horrible content from
him while he practiced but still
another says this dork calls Disney
execs groomers and then joins the cast
of an ABC reality show
another says I'm done with Dancing with
the Stars Matt Walsh is going to be on
it is Disney struggling that they need a
transphobic on their show WTF
now there were many many more where
these came from as the left cried out in
protest against my very real inclusion
in Dancing with the Stars I was trending
Nationwide on Twitter due to the outrage
about this all of these leftists were
convinced and rightly so that it must be
me and no other Matt Walsh because there
is no other Matt Walsh I am the ultimate
Matt Walsh I am the only Matt Walsh the
others have faded into dust Blown Away
by the wind I am the last of the Matt
Walsh's still standing
still dancing
now this is the most important thing to
understand
for all those on the left who have been
asking why is Matt Walsh on the show why
do they give him a platform what is he
doing there
the answer is that I'm there to dance
I am on the show to tell my story and to
reveal what is hidden deeply in my heart
Through The Art of Dance
and you know something dance transcends
politics it breaks through ideological
barriers
it speaks to a deeper truth that lies
inside all of us
this is why I have always turned to
dance even in my darkest moments and
moments of turmoil and confusion
I've always had dance there to bring
Clarity and Light
and that's what I intend to do on
Dancing With the Stars when I appear on
the show which I am really going to do
in real life because this is an actual
thing that is true and that is happening
um look
I'm not going to claim that I'm the best
dancer who's ever danced though I did
perform for one Summer with the New York
City Ballet so I'm certainly no no
novice but my dances is not meant to be
technically perfect my dances are bold
Innovative sometimes provocative even
shocking
I want you to watch me dance and admire
the beauty of the routine but I also
want you to think
I want you to be challenged
you know I learned to dance under the
tutelage of the great Russian
choreographer Victor cortivliov and he
told me something that's always stuck
with me as a dancer he said to dance is
to speak
and to speak is to dance
I don't think that really means anything
but the point is that dance is
self-expression intensely personal and
yet paradoxically public
and I can go on and on about about dance
about my passion for it my relationship
to it about my Years Learning dance from
the Russian guy I just made up but I
think that misses the point
the point is that these people
complaining about my appearance on the
show are missing a real opportunity for
Unity you know a chance to be elevated
above their Petty political concerns
and either way they need to just accept
it I am appearing on the show me Matt
Walsh
now I will warn you
uh I might look a little different when
you see me on the show and practicing
pretty hard takes a lot out of me all
the stance practice might make me look
older balder
it might make my beard fall off uh and
even for some reason it might change the
color of my hair and I want you to be
prepared for that because it can be a
little bit jarring but when they
announced Matt Walsh and I Come Dancing
up on that stage
you should know that it's really me and
nobody else
unless he sucks in which case it's that
deep guy
anyway what matters most is the dance
and to those who can't see that who are
focused more on their personal
resentment towards me than the
opportunity to experience the magic of
dance together
all I can say is that they are all today
canceled
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there